[Music]
in started from the bottom news
submitted by 10-mile hike to a please
[ __ ] that's pretty that's a lot that's
a lot oh my god hours and hours and you
can do that absolutely [ __ ] not did
are you insane
could barely [ __ ] walk a mile a NASA
intern and Buddha PhD student explains
how he went from living in his car to
living his dream they say my dream
Nick dreamer where's his dream at he
wants to become an astronaut so he
hasn't gotten there yet but he's working
towards do you gotta have 20/20 vision
to be astronaut you know you got to be
like a pilot you have to have 20/20
right yeah I'm thinking like maybe am
astronauts need a shih tzu maybe you
just need to know my ass when you're in
the spaceship do they they type in
coordinates and then when it launches it
just goes to that destination or someone
like actually like flying it like a
plane they just shoot it up and see what
happens so you don't know there's kind
of checks and balances and there's
probably person applying it and
following those coordinates and all that
stuff you know what I didn't know but in
Pasadena there's a really respected like
tech college like Tech yeah I didn't
know it's one of the best nations are up
here yeah I didn't grow up here so I
Drive by that [ __ ] place all the time
and the clip was like dude that's like
the MIT of this Coast this and a whole
bunch of people granted they become
astronauts
that's where JPL is Jet Propulsion
laboratories that's amazing like I just
drove by it like it was some random
building and I didn't know that there
was funky genius is in there now just
want to kidnap them you know what I
really hope is that if they're willing
to send a monkey out there to test then
they'll send someone just a little bit
smarter than the monkey which is me to
put up there and then don't send the
real astronaut I don't think you could
do space I think you go crazy
oh yeah wiggly dude I could [ __ ] [ __ ]
there better
breaking all the buttons is [ __ ] I mean
we're just going there and coming back
right yeah I could do it what if
something wrong happens you not thinking
about the possibilities what if I go up
there and meet some aliens bring them
back and I'd be like guess what Julia
there is life out there and I got some
secret technology let me take you other
space technology because Buzz Aldrin
he's afraid to talk about the moon
because there's a [ __ ] alien base
there and he's noted but the NASA told
him to shut the [ __ ] up about it because
the people are ready to know that
there's [ __ ] aliens out there you
know I don't believe in conspiracy but I
[ __ ] love it
hmm you know I mean like all that [ __ ]
like I don't it's interesting it's
fascinating that's like what really
happened yeah like ancient aliens all
the sort of [ __ ] I just don't give a
[ __ ] but I just I enjoy the story it's
like folklore or even like the whole JFK
you don't believe it but like I almost
have existed isn't there like a famous
book on just nothing that you mean you
can read this I think it's called like
something pill horse or something hold
up a white horse like a CIA
ex-cia agent that [ __ ] whistle blows
about the government but then I heard
other resources that has been debunked
oh but I don't know but I like Greek
mythology like be most I think it's
[ __ ] fantastic I'm with you I want to
like pray to like a god I mean he comes
down Wow and just in all of his glory
and then his children are born out of
his [ __ ] head yeah yeah you know
what's funny you know how like in our
image we think he's like a seven-foot
warrior like Thor what if he comes down
and it's like a three-foot to peak Oh
so disappointed I'm God a beauty like
this Bannister a problem
yeah so this story is about Andrew he
grew up in East LA whoa yes here yes
yeah hey so did I yeah with a single mom
and a sister so they're saying that with
his unfortunate childhood he was not
expected to go to college he says quote
there were people at school doing meth
and cocaine in the class room next to
mine getting forced on the school bus
whoever took part of it but it was
always around me only twenty percent of
his class receive diplomas Wow yeah he
says that he only graduated high school
because he wanted to be an athlete so he
maintained a minimum GPA for athletics
he was a swimmer since the age of six
but an injury costume his dream and so
he became directionless after high
school kind of Andrew they did this guy
huh I don't really like pictures
swimming and injuries that much maybe he
loved dislocated shoulder maybe he's bad
soldier soldier this why does he have a
soldier there you go you're stupid as
[ __ ]
I'm the one that speaks weird here don't
take that from me get away from me how
much attention you pay so after high
school he took on four minimum-wage jobs
wait minimum wage for minimum wage
barely on he was working up to 80 hours
a week oh damn he could barely afford
his rent he became aggravated by life he
dies well
speaking American he said quote I felt
like I was meant for something more than
retail I didn't want an education just
for money I was working at the Citadel
that's why I was from Lee's eyes to gas
the Nike three bucks he says I hate it
he didn't want an education just for the
money he wanted to find something
fulfilling and so he decided to put off
college until he could figure out what
he really wanted to do and then several
semesters went by he decided to take
vocational exams to see what was
recommended to him
Oh percent of those exams pointed
towards engineering oh wow he has an
engineering mind yeah he said that he
had no idea what that job entailed so he
researched it like build engines or
something what if he doesn't know what
it is else no it's like an engine inside
of earlobe or something what's going on
engineer and he ended up narrowing it
down to optical engineering because he
had a fascination with lasers I'm stupid
because when I heard optical engineering
I thought it was glasses it seems like
it does it's like somewhere along the
lines of that with laser somehow I'm not
sure exactly but we're awesome yeah but
then he ended up taking seven math
courses over a year and a half trying to
get credits to transfer to a four-year
university that's rough yeah his
financial aid had run out and he started
living out of his car she said quote I
started in November but when December
rolls around I knew I was in trouble
even though it was Los Angeles when he
got down to 55 degrees I was freezing my
ass off 55 degrees another quarter he's
from Sacramento so he has a real win
terrific and even that's not even a real
that's not a real answer yeah like 30
degrees is [ __ ] cold and that's a
Sacramento winner growing up and living
in one like cuz he he's from LA so I
guess maybe he got used to not having
you up from LA in 55 degrees is like the
polar region for us you don't know no I
do know cuz like 55 degrees because
you're from up there you're used to that
we're not that's his point no understand
yeah it's anyway so then he still pushed
forward he quit most of his jobs worked
only 15 hours a week so that he could
spend all of his time
Matt he ended up doing about 60 math
problems a date yeah
Asian upbringing right there when a car
started breaking down he began looking
harder for financial aid previously he
thought that only geniuses or amazing
athlete would qualify Dettol stories
exactly so then once he completed his
credits he got accepted to University of
Arizona oh cool he applied to all the
relevant scholarships you just went from
one East LA to another East LA
University of Arizona had a lot of white
people it depends on which one because
it's like you weigh like you weigh this
you way that you weigh this you and it's
like [ __ ] you see you know like this
one that one here you see that well you
see this one you see them all and he's
saying that he applied to all the
scholarships he used crowdfunding
websites to raise money for his tuition
and his four hundred and fifty dollar a
month or rent you didn't buy any
furniture he never turned on his AC in
Arizona stuff on the floor he ate
potatoes for three months straight
your Stone Cold Steve Austin yeah
Arizona is [ __ ] hot in the summer
like it's so hot that I was like dude
this feels like a sauna I was in Phoenix
just walking around like dude it was so
hot in Arizona this summer that garbage
cans melted yeah yeah and mailbox
mailboxes like the plastic fake walls
people were baking in their cars yeah
it's crazy yeah why do you say that with
the smile because she likes cookies Oh
actual baking I don't like people coming
from me like you put cookies in the
glove compartment and the top of the
windows [ __ ] and you were thinking
people were like dying in their cars
she's like they're fake really so I
immediately thought people were putting
like like a banana bread and [ __ ] inside
their car yeah
baked inside their cars anyways back to
Endor so then one summer he got an
internship with NASA in space
communications and navigation as
dad this kid is awesome and so now he's
beginning a six year program towards his
PhD in optical engineering his
forretress first year has been fully
covered but he's saying that usually
PhDs are funded only for the first year
and then after students just have to
find their own way so he's still trying
can I say this I like this kid because
persevering he goes to college for the
right reasons he doesn't go to college
for credits or units he goes to find
what his purpose in life is yeah
that's why I like him so I think like
that's pretty cool cuz it took me a
while to figure that out you know I mean
it took me like five years and cause I
realize I don't actually like college it
I don't need it for what I want you know
but he actually goes there for the right
reasons just like I need to get these
years because I need him really figure
out and on top of that too he didn't go
to a college until he could figure out
what his direction was before he
wouldn't start wasting money that's true
cuz a lot of people they choose a school
first just because it's prestigious and
then they they go there and they find
some stupid-ass major that's not even
what the school is known for yeah hi
[ __ ] love this kid man I love anything
that's so cool Andrew I like Kali what
else like is that he'd even know
engineering was and his knives getting
PhD in it he makes me feel like a so
[ __ ] because he had it worse than me
yeah and with he all you wanted was
financial aid so he could [ __ ] fix
his car all I wanted was financial aid
so I could buy a pound of weed to sell
all you wanted was to go to school so he
could pursue his dreams of being a NASA
guy all I wanted was to maintain good
grades so I could keep selling weed hey
guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it I know you did
but guess what you can also follow us on
our personal social media accounts with
the links in the description box below
so go follow all of us now to watch more
videos check out up there
[Music]